Speaker 1: This is my favorite clip of the
week, possibly of the month, maybe of 2023 so
far. You're going to just sit down for this one.
Okay. If I told you that my racial background was
cock a sword, what would you think? You'd
think something's not right. You'd think,
Oh, boy. David Pakman. Sir, the wheel is spinning,
but the hamster is dead. You would think something
was very wrong with me. Well, that is exactly the
word that Newsmax guest Vernon Jones used during
a segment on Newsmax about when Joe Biden said,
I'm a white boy, but I'm not dumb or something
along those lines. You have to see this. Vernon
Jones. Try God. I think I might just play it and
not even explain it. And I'll explain it later.
Okay. Here is Vernon Jones telling us what are
the three races? What are the three races?
Speaker 2: This is what he said yesterday.
He said, I'm a what? At this church, I'm
a white boy, but I'm not stupid. Vernon,
I mean, we're that. Let me drop back for a
second. First of all, Jason, my good friend,
being Latino is no race. There is only three
races more. Montego Akaka. So hard and Negro.
Speaker 1: Oh, my God. Oh, dear God. There
are three races, folks. Mano gourd, kaka,
sword and negroid. Okay. Do you know where
this comes from? As Dave Weigel pointed out,
our friend Dave Weigel, this is not a random
guy. This is Vernon Jones, who was endorsed by
Trump in 2022. He thankfully lost his primary.
Here is what Vernon Jones is talking about.
There is this old 1780s race idea that there are
essentially three races. Those three races are
caucuses, void Mongoloid and Negroid, or as it
was originally called, Ethiopian. This is from
the 1780s. It comes from the gotten gen school
of history. It was then later developed further
and it became one of these racist ideologies
during the age of colonialism. Okay. So it's
insane that Vernon Jones, particularly as a black
man, is saying this is the reality about race,
but it's extra insane that he's mangling beyond
recognition the names of these races. Cock a
sword. What on earth? I mean, it sounds like it
sounds like when when little boys play swords,
if you know what I'm talking about. It's insane.
Let's play it one more time. Absolutely. My
favorite clip maybe of the year so far.
Speaker 2: Vernon. I mean, we're that.
Let me drop back for a second.
First of all, Jason, my good friend.
Speaker 1: Dropped back to
contextualize Corky's sword. For us.
Speaker 2: Being Latino was no race. There was
only three races. Marlon McMonagle had conquer so
hard and Negro and.
Speaker 1: Oh.
Well, it's You couldn't write this stuff.
Speaker 2: But liberals create this whole new
class or a new race called Latinos. They are no
race. And it is it is very clear he did say that
that Hispanics are more diverse in their thinking
than African-American, not diverse. And where they
come from, as a matter of fact, Spaniards have
nothing to do with Mexicans and they all speak
the same language. But again.
Speaker 1: Well, I think it's
good. I think Spaniards have something to
do with Mexicans. If you study the history
of the Spanish, why do you think that
Spanish is spoken in most but not all,
Central and South American countries? Now,
of course, now in Mexico, the population is
many. You have a lot of multiracial ism in
Mexico, which is folks from Spain who then
had kids with those populations that were already
in what is now Mexico. But what has anyone ever
heard a dumber analysis of whatever this is.
Speaker 2: Going to create this race if
you and made a unique based on you
speaking Hispanic. I speak speaking.
Speaker 1: I speak Hispanic. That's exactly right.
Speaker 2: So our Spanish. Yeah. So let's
be clear about that, too.
Speaker 1: This is a verbal
inkblot. This is just a mess.
Speaker 2: Joe Biden stands in
front of a black college like Morehouse and
Spelman. He says that the reason why black
businesses aren't as successful as whites
is because they don't have lawyers and they
don't have a counters that is racist, nastier,
without naive. He here he is. And they say he's
80 now saying that. How about when Joe was in
80 when Joe didn't want black people to go in
his neighborhood and go to school? I didn't
hear Carla Harris say it. So Joe has a long
history of bigotry. Joe has a long bigotry.
Speaker 1: All right. Anyway, I want you to
email me, let me know if there was a if you
were running a5k or playing intramural hockey,
are you going to be on Mano Goard or do you prefer
to be on what I believe is the winning team,
the Kaka Swords? I know. I know where I'm
going with this one, folks. You let me know.